[Musique]
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
antenne 2 et philips l'inventeur du
compact disc vous présente double jeu
l'émission de thierry ardisson
[Musique]
m
il y aura
[Musique]
non
ce soir au programme de double jeu
retrouvé natalie cole la fille de nat
king cole grammy du meilleur album 91 et
l'autre jean marie bigard pas bigeard
connard plus marco les autres émissions
le façon dans un mois plus les infos
intox de philippe guérin les salles
black laurent baffie philippe corti
l'omoplate indoor l'invité vedette yves
lacoste
allez messieurs bonsoir et bienvenue aux
folies bergères pour double alors
mais pour jouer avec nous ce soir c'est
un ami de la famille il a un talent fou
sans air sympa s de l'info ouais ça faux
culs en tout cas merci à tous car chaque
semaine c'est de plus en plus nombreux à
ne plus pouvoir l'encadré ses filiales
philippe alors face à lui celui qu'on
croyait tout simplement grossier
maintenant c'est qu'il est aussi
bêtement vulgaire voici dolan pas fait
du pape
laurent baffie
notre invité de ce soir c'est en prenant
la voix des autres qu'il a trouvé la
sienne
mais ce qu'avec l'âge et le succès le
coq en pâte on va le savoir tout de
suite
yves lecoq
m
[Musique]
pas très bon soir ça peux tu me dire que
les insultes qui t'a fait le plus mal
c'est une insulte que j'entends souvent
malheureusement c'est quand on écrit
patrick ça je supporte pas parce que
j'ai peur qu'on le confonde avec
quelqu'un d'autre avec patrick sabatier
patrick sébastien et je tiens à lire ce
soir mon prénom c'est quand même maurice
quoi maurice qu'est ce que tu as de plus
sexy en toi pour certaines c'est ma voix
cassé ma voix café maurice qu'est ce que
tu écris quand on me demande des
autographes
j'ai envie d'écrire des tas de choses
avec des cris je t'aime c'est super
c'est génial c'est finalement je n'ai
rien à dire parce que le fait qu'on me
demande d'autographe examen s'est suffi
quoi y'a rien à ajouter c'est déjà super
est-ce que tu thème souvent je me pose
cette question quand même atteint dans
la glace et je dis ce que je suis en
adéquation avec moi-même et finalement
il ya des jours oui ce jour non mais
depuis quelque temps on y chante j'ai
vraiment trouvé un personnage avait
vraiment à coeur qui s'est révélé que
j'aime beaucoup
maurice tu crois qu'il faut coucher pour
réussir je pense pas mais je pense qu'il
faut réussir pour coucher c'est vrai dis
moi c'est pas dur de devenu une star au
moment du sida je veux que toute façon
le start i stand c c'est un formidable
préservatif ça vous préserver quelque
chose entre république et vous qui se
passe qui est complètement platonique et
ça c'est grand c'est beau et je pense
qu'en courent pas de risques
quand as-tu pleurer pour la dernière
fois j'ai pleuré à montpellier je crois
ou à bordeaux chez plus fins sont les
personnes mangent à toulouse en fait
c'était comment j'avais envie de pleurer
j'ai pleuré dans ma loge mais je serai
aussi devant biarritz car je tiens à le
dire
et après demain je veux être avant du
son je crois que je peux réussir tu
préfères draguer tout faire draguer j'ai
pas le choix de toute façon on mènera
tous les soirs c'était 15000 à bordeaux
je crois 12000 à montpellier celui qui
me draguent ce fossé su c'est quelque
chose qui nous dépasse kouassem jeu pour
empêcher à montluçon ils sont combien
chat qui seront passibles 12000 hacker
réservation ils sont nombreux parce
qu'elle escompte rédigeant la fin c'est
la fête quoi c'est génial c'est à quoi
reconnaît-on infailliblement la passion
naissante la patience et cesser la
flamme cesser la flamme d'un briquet
qu'on allume coincé et puis être flammes
puis le briquet plus être patient et
puis plus la couche d'ozone aussi
maintenant prendre et la passion qui
s'éteint c'est quand y'a plus de gaz
merci morice
alors je te voir prendre la voie et la
peau des autres on a fini par oublier
qu'il y avait un vrai le coq aussi
d'ailleurs à toi aussi ça t'arrive qui
d'ailleurs ça peut pas du tout le coq
mais lecoquierre oui mais on m'appelait
quand même déjà le coq au lycée donc je
gardais le ce dos et la première voie
que su faire c'est de gaulle non j'ai
peut-être eu conscience d'imitation avec
avec de gaulle mais j'en ai je me suis
en avoir fait avant sans savoir que ceux
des imitations jeu je puisais ma source
dans les discothèques de mai seraient
donc c'était c'était bécaud c'était
grimaud et aujourd'hui tu peux en faire
combien et aujourd'hui j'en fais
une centaine de voix parlée
j'en ai en stock certainement un peu
plus mais de celles qui se pratique
qu'on reconnaît encore 1 à 100 et puis
autant de chanter s'ébattent était alors
plus + wii survient gigamic pas encore
lu est-ce que la perfection occuper seul
et ce qu'ils me voient justement est-ce
qu'à une boîte justement qu'il fait
mieux que l'original ou quelques fois
j'ai entendu dire des victimes
attention parce que tu chantes trop bien
je vais avoir du mal à timité quelqu'un
qui ait eu cet état du monstre pierre
perret où le champagne parce que t'es
trop juste et toi qui s'est imiter c'est
pareil je sois moi-même déjà mais
aujourd'hui qui fait quand même beaucoup
plus de gars là que les gens qui imitent
souvent c'est à dire que c'est la
solution de facilité dont on est sûr
d'en avoir pour tous les goûts
ouais on soutenir un imitateur il ya
vingt stars sur ce à quoi
ouais donc c'est bon marché pour les
patriots et intime le brame pour toi
serait le rhume sur la seule chose qu'il
faut être bien dans la rue ou
l'extinction de voix je voudrais arriver
aussi
il pourrait faire morose et william ont
alors eu également un décodeur ce soir
là c'est vrai que ce à quoi ce sera
super meat et que lui françois mauriac
oublié et je m'en allais oublier oui est
ce qui t'arrive lead de prendre une voie
de séducteur des fois je parle pas au
lit il est jamais une fille quitte à 10
ont plusieurs ce set après ce qu'elle
recherche chez moi est-ce que c'est pas
dur de vivre avec tous ces personnages
qui triby ses 100 personnages qui
habitent ta tête
non mais j'avais bien compris c'était au
dessus de la ceinture
non parce que j'ai en fait je mens comme
j'en ai beaucoup oui je m'en débarrasse
facilement ouais je parle des
personnages et la foule causant une fois
que ce sera vraiment travail de mercy 1
est seul chez toi et tu ailles de parler
avec à haute voix avec la voix d'un
autre mais tu raconte ce que tu fais par
exemple un fusil et un café en racontant
comment tu te fais un café avec la boîte
poivre d'arvor ou drucker mais là c'est
un sacré car c'est bien serré et kanté
façe tutu prend facilement la boîte qui
quand je suis fâché je suis plutôt
sémavoine utilise que d'ailleurs on ne
reconnaît pas parce que je suis pas
souvent sachez alors quoi surpris tu
veux tu peux pas fini
et quoique bonne humeur tu prends la
boîte qui est jean pierre foucault
c'est at il dit non bon c'est un don
génial de la nature que tu as parce que
d'abord ce rapport plein de blé ensuite
tu fais rire les gens j'ai mis un
centime à mouler patiemment la fin dès
le ce1 10 ans assis chez harris ans
quand il a tué depuis très très cher dis
moi tu sais qu'il ya un autre don de la
nature que tu as
je suis sûr que tu le sais pas je ne
sais pas tu sais pas ses yeux clairs
c'est un enfant ouais les yeux bleus et
s'est pas démenti non t'as pas de l'anti
là non
marc gardois francon petit téléviseur et
regarde j'ai s'entend je suis bien
pourtant
près de 6000 français sont centenaires
d'antoine pinay 100 ans à jeanne calment
la doyenne de l'humanité 117 ans nous
vivons de plus en plus vieux un médecin
a tenté de percer ce secret dans un
livre publié aux éditions du cherche
midi
on y apprend que les personnes aux yeux
clairs en plus de chances de devenir
centenaire que celle aux yeux foncés
elles sont toutes tournées vers le futur
c'est à dire que elle voit plus
aujourd'hui comme la veille de demain
que comme le lendemain d'hier alors une
fausse serait pas si l'air c'est la
couleur de leurs cieux alors qu'en
france la répartition de la couleur des
yeux
en gros deux tiers de dieu foncée marron
noir épique un tiers des yeux clairs
chez les centenaires on a plus de la
moitié qui ont les yeux clairs bleu ou
vert et puis environ 40% qui ont les
yeux marrons et noisettes ou brun et
c'est pas du tout la réversion qu'on met
dans l'ensemble de la population
française pas je les fais vieux je vis
et je vois que le principal non les yeux
clairs peuvent pourtant triomphé
ils sont les facteurs héréditaires d'une
longévité exceptionnelle
je pense que je peux venir chanter ça
merveilleux
j'attends ça avec impatience mais ça ne
sera pas long alors je me suis bien
voyez je vais partir chez moi à la
campagne je vais me connais je vais rien
faire je vais faire des patiences je
vais aller me prendre mais je m'occupais
mes fleurs et j'espère garder loison
jusqu'à jusqu'à 100 ans mais les
centenaires brune qui dans cette étude
compte une fois encore pour des prunes
n'ont guère apprécié elle conteste
l'explication scientifique
oui mais j'avais pas le centenaire
d'après vous vous fait rire avec ses
vrais puis c'est pas vrai je ne sais pas
me lire
plus de chances de devenir centenaire
avec les yeux clairs s de l'info s de
l'intox
yves lecoq à l'oreille je fais pas une
bois j'ai lu ma petite fille chez denise
way de change de devenir centenaire
quand on a les yeux clairs comme yves
lecoq s de l'info ou de l'intox
à ton avis philippe moi je pense que
c'est de l'intox mais pourquoi parce que
j'ai les yeux clairs comme philippe
guérin et hualan aussi de l'info c'est
dans le fond et pour voir si l'info
parce que toi moi je vois très relevé
les yeux noirs tonné me rené duval et du
club du vigilante source toi tu me dis
que c'est de l'info aussi ouais pourquoi
ça te fait plaisir
non non je tiens le valais sont enquis
ça parce que c'est plausible alors avec
votre expert philippe guérin
alors si nous c'est de l'info c'est de
l'intox tu vas voir que le sosie de ma
fille va donner toutes les bonnes
réponses c'est de l'info bravo
est ce que le dira originale un
commentaire à faire bien sûr l'addition
originale jai un commentaire je suis
très heureux que ça ne soit pas une
intox
c'est une info et ça m'arrange bien
d'ailleurs à ce propos regarder merci
dominique évidemment les valeurs sont
respectées c'est baky qui marque le 1er
point en plus gras est vraiment inquiète
parce qu'il a les réponses loi
alors
on a vu que ton prénom c'était
lecoquierre et un surnom
j'avais un surnom j'étais gosse laâyoune
ah ouais les jukebox tu veux pas le dire
à tout boxe ça c'était au lycée il
paraît qu'on t'appelle jukebox parce que
quand on ne paye qui fait plein de voix
différentes comme un suppôt box soit on
met de l'argent non si j'appuie sur un
but comme ça on doit forcément pour
l'argent c'est pour le plaisir mais
c'est donc c'est ça c'est vrai t'as quel
âge
quand tu le dis et voilà bon bac 1 1 46
ans c'est l'âge d'une petite interview
de chez capter près la taille était
grande
ouais bah tu veux dire toi 20 300
emplois 80 c'est bien bel homme moyen
s'est bâti l'équipe sébastien est plus
gros ses partisans
elles sont commentés denrées sont bien
nous attends je vais te faire sabatier
je vous aime et à l'est elles sont bien
propre et où tu fume pas je vous aime
pas c pour ca t1 à combien d'origine
j'en ai ma sympathie va l'appliquer 4
28 28 tu as les cheveux gras ou sacs
blancs et les yeux alors bon ils sont
clairs on a dû donc très longtemps tu
porte pas de lunettes ils portent pas de
l'anti comme un de sinclair c'est myope
pas du tout presbytes n'en prit
astigmate que j'ai quelques stigmates à
élaguer profession du père il était
officier de marine et donc et la mer ma
mère a donné des 100 piano de fait
l'armée
quinze jours pourquoi est-on pas gardé
non j'ai les cheveux trop longs
non mais qu'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
vestiaires et l'armée se porte plutôt
way formule première expérience sexuelle
du temps souviens assez terrible dépend
ce qu'on appelle expérience sexuelle
déjà tout nu avec une période en
personne même si a pas pénétration situé
avant alors je viens touche manque quoi
aller dans le foin dans le foin quel âge
ça pique
ouais 12 ans 12 ans et c'est bien mais
la précoce avant que les ces années de
la disputation consentants elle est
épatante en tant qu'associé de suspect
si nécessaire certains traumatisés ils
vont pas du tout pas du tout
fréquence hebdomadaire des rapports
sexuels
ça vous fait rire 2 2 cette météo n'est
jamais que 18 noms 1-2 majeur recul pour
mieux se
et qu'en général je veux dire le samedi
soir après le turbin non non non il n'y
a pas de pas de danse peut être
n'importe quand ça peut être avant une
émission sans fin et la lra décontractée
ça fait ça fait listings en gnl en fait
ça fait du bien coût des cultures un
petit coup d'éclat petit coup d'éclat
oui tu es déjà ceux déjà été violée
enfin pas au point de partir en courant
mais il ya eu des tentatives quand même
oui une fois l'alliance a abouti ils
étaient plusieurs sinon elle était seule
elle était seul et a sauté dessus
elle m'a sauté dessus et oui je sais
faire bah oui parce que je voulais pas
quand même me traite de pds que tu as eu
recours dans ta vie à l'amour tarifé
quoi mais je n'ai jamais eu besoin de
payer pour ça pour l'instant
d'ailleurs pour moi c'est pas certain
qu'il ait pas eu besoin il perdra des
gens me disant tiens ce ces deux là ça
coûte ça coûte temps un appartement je
paye sa menotte l'envi sa propre
sébastien il paye ses hanches jours est
ce que tu as des perversions sexuelles
non enfin qui sont à vous abattez des
visions si tu veux mais non je comprends
j'ai pas l'impression d'être un pervers
non au grand chose d'un peu bcbg coince
avant les rapports
est ce que par exemple tu te déguiser en
aveugle pour faire là seulement que ces
montagnes et parce que ben film en maths
et demi il est capable
la glace fihg
c'est c'est monique vous n'êtes pas du
tout dans le coup à fond on est un opéra
ici et madame non on ne tarde pas de
royal annonce coûté on était au coeur je
connais bien sûr plaisantez ou quoi
nota palais royal ici oui des shebab
on est bien au coeur a quand même si
monsieur justement vous êtes un non
voyant et si vous vous êtes trompés mais
un type ans a traversé pendant
des traversées pour vous avez vous allez
droite mme en fait je veux dire vous
traversiez
attendez vous êtes homosexuel pas du
tout giacomo sexuelle nous venons vous
voulez gérer la matinée vous me jurez ce
que je viendrais versées mais j'avais
emmené avec moi
allez bonne oui alors on est là on va la
toucher
comment ça peut aller segments sont
prenants michel michel a des bonnes en
travers alors je lui propose de lui au
travers son travail bombinette
échangiste et échangistes
voilà ce que moi je traverse pour
l'outaouais michel c'est pas possible de
le louper les oeuvres volées louvel est
là mais j'ai rien à faire au louvre par
vous alors là c'est les verts font la
rue par là vous allez allez c'est
vraiment vous faire plaisir ce que c'est
pas du tout ma direction est là mais je
vais opéra j'y suis c'est bon non pas
des royals ont chopé un jeu cassation
pour le changement en présentant des
états palais royal je vous le dis pas
les vrais musée du louvre à cheval dans
la bulle encore et c'est ma chance
ailleurs des pavages alors charger sur
l'expression
là encore vous d où je le sache je vois
rien donné des mois alors je sais pas
vous être autrement embrouilles et là je
vous demandez rien ou me sauter dessus
vous commencez à me faire chier
maintenant je vous aider à traverser
parce qu'on sait jamais venez venez
c'est plus prudent et qu'un aveugle
pression les pouvoirs pareil alors vous
avez vous aider voilà voilà
faites attention à vos 1 les havrais va
la revoir demande
alors on va continuer quand même avec la
face cachée d'yves lecoq
on a déjà découvert plein de choses on
va continuer parce que quelque chose que
les gens savent peu c'est que tu es
châtelain alors ton père était officier
de marine il des pachas teintées
officier de marine ta mère était prof de
piano est ta grand-mère était antiquaire
mais en fait ça vient de là tu l'adoré
taximen oui forte personnalité très
marrante très jeune mais c'est un sacré
personnage parce que il paraît qu'ils
étaient copines avec la gac an et 15
jours à l'avenir et la duchesse de
windsor de chez elle ah oui la duchesse
de windsor voulait pas payer les
factures
oui elle payée par 1 5 milliard venant
tation donc ça n'intéressait pas parce
qu'il n'avait pas les moyens de faire
est là crédit à la duchesse demi soeur
alors en 68 est devenu antiquaires tu as
repris la boutique j'ai eu la chance
quand même de voir ce que me disent la
boutique et va quand est ce que tu veux
la reprendre et j'ai sauté là dessus et
parallèlement à ça j'ai continué d
études de l'histoire de l'art qui était
à mon avis plus parallèle à ce que
j'aimais ce que je faisais je préférais
quand même à prendre ce genre de
matières ce canal loyers par exemple
qu'est ce que t'en prends ça va dans le
décor ça vaut combien connaissent et me
15 rococo ça c'est une copie faubourg
saint-antoine alors
avoir fait pas ça vaut quelque fois plus
cher que les originaux d'ailleurs l'état
bon à savoir
j'ai bien fait de l'acheter témoin tu
l'as acheté ouais tu t'es fait avoir
mais tu as tu es tu as fait des choses
d'ailleurs tu as tué des corps est un
peu le bureau de m c'est là une boutique
d'antiquités c'est pas tellement marrant
de rester attendre le client surtout
quand c'est dans une rue qui est pas
très fréquentée alors je faisais
d'autres choses je faisais des
décorations de
deux films quand on m'a proposé de
bureau et
c'est comme ça que je suis rentré à la
radio d'ailleurs en décorant et mc
rentrée d'aller fouler ma propre
moquette peut-être pas eu peur si tu
t'es dit si je reste antiquaires je vais
finir en vieille folle efféminé comme on
voit dans les films c'est ça comme dans
la chanson
non je pense que ça ça m'aurait pas du
tout afflux est influencé mais c'est
vrai que j'avais envie de faire autre
chose est sûre que l'antiquité sait plus
maintenant pour moi un passe temps que
c'était un que c'était un but à l'époque
c'est aussi une ruine et honorine
parce que en parlant de ruines qui a
deux châteaux faim qu'ils sont plus des
ruines d'ailleurs que tu restes or que
tu retard parisien qui s'appelle suzanne
oui et c'est vrai qu'ils avaient écrit
au la crête avait il ya toujours écrit à
la crête sur le génial voilà non mais
c'est je pense que c'est un truc que tu
raconté aux journalistes sur les murs
est gravé sur les plafonds et sur les
murs c'est faux la crête c'était la
devise du des chapelains d'estourmel sur
les remparts de jérusalem ou au xième
siècle quand ils allaient quand ils
allaient récupérer le latéral
dans ce cas un sens et c'est quand tu es
là bas tu ta vie en fait là non pas
exagérer je suis plus souvent en jeans
dégueulasse et on dit souvent qu'il
valait broca le côté pas là mais je vois
son jardinier souvent les gens disent
mais des brancards ça peux m'amuser oui
le matin de m c'est peut-être pour ça
aussi que j'ai créé un catogan
c'était venus commence catogan parce que
tu as dit un jour il ya une fille sur la
plage qui a voulu attaché mon cm 2 que
alors c'est vrai que quand on lit ces à
la première fois on s'est passé
tellement con mais je suis modeste
ouais bah oui c'est vrai que c'est comme
ça a commencé comme ça hein mais c'était
là que derrière est évidemment c'était
simplement pour le côté pratique il a
bien poussé il fait bien dix huit
centimètres avait ça c'est ce qu'on veut
il paraît que tu es 5 lecture constitue
le décor à la petite cuillère près c'est
vrai ça oui j'aime bien que dans une
pièce on puisse se dire voyons si on est
sous le bon roi louis louis 15 en
l'occurrence
est-ce que tout serait conforme aux
décors de dire qu'il faut pas qu'on voit
un bouton électrique faut qu'il est il
faut que tout soit en place quand même
si la table est mise depuis les verts
jusqu'au petite cuillère puis va souvent
ses châteaux selon mes activités
- comme air que tu dis par exemple et
c'est tout à fait prendre ça tu dis j'y
vais le week-end pour payer les factures
et mes gardiens vivent toute la semaine
une vie de châtelain là bas ça peu
exagéré parce qu'ils ont beaucoup de
boulot et que en plus il contribue
beaucoup à la restauration des lieux
mais c'est vrai que ces deux qui restent
fait de l'élevage là bas on donne l
usage personnel
quoi par exemple quelques poules bon
bravo une hache ouais charmante juliette
qui le suit partout
c'est celle qui a été opérée en direct
dans l'émission de du bovin du bourg
nuit exactement elle fait depuis un veau
par à tapas de moutons que j'en ai eu
mais ils ont vieilli et je sais pas
remplacé parce que je n'attache proulx
est ce que quand il était très vieux des
moutons tuent leurs amis des dentiers
non mais je ne sais pas elle avait
encore des dents la dernière est morte à
12 ans quitte à g pour un mouton et elle
avait encore des dents est mais elle
broutait genou s'est pas donné plus
qu'une base est ce qu'il faut faire
dis moi oui non si c'est s'est pas tu
veux voir un truc sur les entiers pour
moutons le temps des chantiers alors moi
je veux bien qu'on me tu vas voir il
s'appelle pierre mayer il est français
et en l'espace de huit ans il est devenu
le premier exportateur mondial dans un
domaine très particulier celui de la
prothèse dentaire ovine
cet industriel niçois fabrique ici dans
son laboratoire un dentier pour moutons
standard bon marché qui permet de sauver
des milliers de têtes de bétail à
travers le monde
j'ai simplement fait une multiplication
60 millions de têtes en europe
cet être 15% qui sont atteints par cette
affection une multiplication autant de
prothèses marchés existants celui que
nous avons attaqué en premier bien
entendu l'europe avec un bon pied en
angleterre nous avons fait ensuite
l'essentiel de notre implantation sur
l'australie actuellement nous sommes en
train de développer une autre unité de
production en nouvelle zélande les
marchés en cours de négociation simple
et l urss et nous nous sommes dirigés
vers la chine
la prothèse dentaire pour mouton est né
en angleterre c'est à ce jour la
meilleure solution que l'on ait trouvé
pour enrayer la prod on cite une
infection d'origine bactérienne qui
s'attaque aux dons du mouton et qui
entraîne sa mort la france utilise ce
dentier depuis quinze ans à la demande
du vétérinaire je suis venu aujourd'hui
pour appareiller 60 proby qui sont
partiellement ou totalement édenté alors
il me suffit d'enduire la base intérieur
de la prothèse avec une colle qui est
très résistante d'appliquer le tout
fermement en bouche pendant une minute
dans une demi-heure l'animal pourra
reprendre ses fonctions masticatoire et
s'alimentait comme auparavant pierre
mayer a exporté l'année dernière 700
milles dentier pour nous tous
alizée un chiffre d'affaires de 60
millions de francs de quoi pousser
quelques cocorico c'est important le
côté cocardier un petit peu l'image de
la france qui gagne c'est moi je donne
toujours des chiffres
la balance commerciale qui s'effondre le
commerce extérieur t'es pas bon des gens
qui disent ça va s'améliorer et cetera
et cetera
pour une fois on est devant les autres
pour une fois on bat les les anglais et
les australiens
la mairie spectateurs de ganthier pour
moutons s-21 fourès de l'intox
yves lecoq à l'oreille ouais alors
mesdames messieurs pendant que vous
réfléchissez pendant que philippe guérin
et laurent baffie réfléchissent ici
qu'est ce qu'on écoute corti je suis pas
sur les coupes de bigard de toute
manière tout c'est bien avec violence
je le dédie à la réunion des comics
si j'y vais ce que les comics on se
connaît tous on se réunit bon bah ouais
je les dis à la dernière réunion
moi je me suis pas gêné moi je me suis
levé j'ai dit les gars ça fait quatre
ans que je fais le vulgaire
je voudrais bien décrocher un petit peu
qu'ils me promener en laye personnes
alex sims zouk romain personne personne
vous
alors je dis alors ya des gens qui
souffrent dans les campings et ya
personne pour s'en occuper
personne n'aurait vu ça les bougies
n'allait bedossa ils sont dans leurs
journaux ça les intéresse pas le
vulgaire alors si un moment donné il ya
sabatier qui s'est levée parce que les
gones la télé ils viennent aux réunions
à lui dis moi j'aime bien le prendre le
vulgaire j attends patrick heures il y
en a déjà pris la bonté la charité et
les pleurnicheries bien tu vas quand
même pas prendre le vulgaire en plus un
c'est un gros morceau le vulgaire un
repas de mettre ça sur le dos tu vas me
le faire bon alors qu'ils doutent et
study geek
si tu gardes les intervilles mairie tu
les gardes reggae dans ses pas de ça
qu'on parle guy à
parce qu'il faut les voir ils sont
chacun leur truc les gars toi tu as pop
est qu'il est dans le fond il dit les
gars quand est ce qu'on réintègre
garcimore dire hip hop est en phase avec
benfica n'a dû faire bien on n'est pas
là dessus alors je vous écoute
qu'est ce que tu dis plus vulgaire que
la guerre tu ne l'est guère à temps
raymond raymond si tu profites des
réunions pour rod et escaich raymond il
ya un an n'avance pas d'un poil moi j'ai
posé une question qui est simple
j'aurais savoir qu' ici veut reprendre
le vulgaire l'aria personne même pas les
a mis là
muriel pierre valérie albert laurent
patrick les inconnus là bas non ils
jouent au billard ils s'en foutent bon
bah moi je veux dire un truc vous êtes
sympas les copains mais moi je suis pas
d'accord pour laisser souffrir des gens
et bien puisque personne ne veut le
faire le vulgaire et ben moi je mets
recolle bord des lacs une [__] de
merde
et puis pas plus que maintenant
la france
exportateurs dentier pour moutons s de
l'info os de la tête
baffie à toi de jouer aussi de
l'auto-stop conneries qu'on se batte
hawks et pourquoi
kouakou kouassi dans le mouton il va à
dentier parce qu'ils vont restituer ce
soit automatique dans le football c'est
90 autres un écart si l'intox
il dit que c'est de l'intox mais
pourquoi parce que mes parents sont
agriculteurs dans le nord pas de calais
depuis des années et qui m'ont jamais
parlé de ça que j'y crois pas ça aussi
tu m'as dit que c'est de l'intox
non je crois oui non on va voir deux
exemples la télévision lé des vins qui
présente des émissions avec des dentiers
nantis longtemps c'est vrai alors on va
savoir ce qu'en pense l'expert philippe
guérin
et oui on peut pas gagner à tous les
coups on peut même perdre parfois 3
contre 1 puisque c'était de l'intox
as tu un commentaire mon fils ou où il
dirigeait un commentaire mon petit
thierry nous c'est de l'intox c'est une
un sujet qui nous a été suggérée par un
téléspectateur de toulon monsieur molle
qui nous envoyait un art de var-matin
datant de 1966 nous avions pensé au
départ en faire une info mais 25 ans
après impossible de retrouver la moindre
trace du dentier pour moutons nous avons
donc fait fabriquer un faux dentier pour
mouton est une intox se proclamant notre
pays premier exportateur mondial de
prothèses pour moutons à mon avis je
suggérerais une petite idée au
prothésiste de patrick sabatier s'il
veut opérer une reconversion rapide et
efficace qui ne se ruent sur cette idée
nous lui donnerons toutes les
coordonnées nécessaires
alors laurent le score est bien la
logique est toujours respecté ça fait 2
1 pour baffie il est fort sa fille en a
produit un peu parano quand même non
alors c'est quoi parano bas par un homme
ça veut dire que tu es toujours un peu
si tu veux tu as un peu pas méchant
enfin ta légère tendance au syndrome
geignard peut dire tu te plains tout le
temps quand on lis tes interviews là tu
es formidable mais en 74 par exemple à
une première histoire c'est que tu sors
un disque et non mais c'est vrai que
j'ai pas eu de bol mais non mais quand
on va on va voir tout ça c'est écrit
mais je m'en plains pas parce que ça m'a
permis d'évoluer mais alors à jour a
interdit le dise pourquoi il interdit de
10 km à vous et parce que quand tu te
fais l'imitation d'une chanson
existantes ou 10 minutes et surtout des
chansons que je parodier tu prends un
texte qui est connu et tu le mets en
forme et pour transformer ce texte vous
demandez l'autorisation de l'auteur et
cite une île n'est pas d'accord il peut
faire complètement intervenir la chose
donc le disque était cassée mais ça
c'est une race qu'autre chose il y avait
25 chansons 25 mutations qu'ont intégré
sur ce disque est à cause du non on a
cassé de france alors fausse garde cet
été j ai fait une chanson berger égale
qui était de jouer du piano debout et
toi tu avais fait geler des pipots
coucher
interdite le disque est sorti séparé
mais s'était retiré à merano mais bon je
chante toujours fait toujours en 80 il
ya eu aussi tu as été interdite
d'antenne c'est une chanson que c'était
mitterrand qui draguait dalida c'est ça
non j'ai pas fait de la présence pour ça
mais c'était effectivement une sorte de
danse où les mitterrand qui danse avec
dalida
le disque est pas passé parce que c'est
l'élection était trop proche trop floue
c'était quoi mais je me suis toujours
demandé si en 80 je ne vais pas arrêter
mes émissions centaines de accoutrement
d'un changement de gouvernement
c'est plutôt ça qui m'a fait actually
voilà tu t'es plainte a dit voilà on m'a
arrêté parce que y avait des missions
qu'ils savaient se suivent et le coq
suivez le coq et étudie j'ai été arrêté
parce que j'avais été choisi par
l'ancien régime
mais j'ai eu l'impression que c'était ça
mais on ne m'a jamais envoyé une lettre
en disant vous êtes plutôt marqué à
droite
ouais on va vous arrêtez votre émission
alors en 85 ça continue des malheurs
c'est terrible une valeur d'yves lecoq
et ça allait à la presse les mâles
visible alors ça tous les gens à bord de
sa nouvelle montant des malheurs des
stars légère compacte du bonheur ça
marche toujours
il ya eu l'histoire en 85 de la pièce de
bones qui s'appelait il ya dans la
guitare basse était un flop c'est tout
mais ça c'est ça peut arriver ça m'a
donné
une expérience du théâtre l'étoile avant
avant la première représentation quand
on parlait de la pièce tu disais je suis
le contexte franchement c'est pas le
soulier de satin
oui j'avais j'avais faire et ça je le
dis est ce que je peux faire quelques
imitations dans pour essayer de les
gagner les choses m'a dit non non c'est
très bien surtout ne changez rien tu
avais déclaré aussi au sujet de cette
pièce qqq pleurs que ça déçoivent ton
public jeu sympa pour l'auteur et
metteur en scène
le producteur du spectacle je sais pas
j'ai dit tout ça là oui bon ben c'est
pas gentil pour les auteurs mais c'était
c'est quand même ça c'est vrai ça c'est
par un échec quand même donc je vais
talent un peu flairé alors dans cette
série les malheurs en 88 dans le
parisien tu déclaré thierry le luron se
sert de ses relations pour qu'on parle
pas beaucoup de moi tu veux dire qu'ils
aient un barrage voila voila c'est
peut-être vrai remarques parce qu'à une
concurrence dans ce métier je dirais
faut pas le nier complètement parano
mais j'avais l'impression quand même que
qu'il avait beaucoup d'amis dans la
presse donc
j'étais n'était pas question pour moi
d'avoir des articles qui me monte en
épingle dans les journaux où il avait
des amis ce qui est bon à une fois de
fidélité de la partisane et michel leeb
si tu as des en parlant de michel leeb à
la même époque ils voient pas d'un très
bon oeil que je m'occupe des molières ah
oui les maliens mais c'est des choses
qu'on me répète et moi comme j'ai
tendance à dire tout ce que j'entends
effectivement ça peut paraître
récriminations la blague est parano
alors après il à faire le la faire le
coq sébastien là la grande affaire sur
tf1 fait quelques couler un peu d'encre
il aurait dit notre ami sébastien deux
imitateurs sur tf1 c'est un trop mais
non mais il a fait certains il a fait
certaines interviews il disait qu
effectivement écrit ce n'était pas une
bonne idée que je sois sur tf1 car le
message disait non moi j'ai tout fait
pour qu'il avait alors entre temps que
tu es parti sur l'a5 ben oui parce que
je sentais comme le terrain miné
c'est vrai que j'ai eu un coup de fil de
patrick qui m'a dit reconnaît que si
j'avais fait la même chose si j'étais
nue sur canal faire les guignols tu
aurais réagi comme moi donc il admis il
admettait quand même ils avaient mal
réagi mais qu'il avait agit normalement
et comme je sentais qu'il y avait quand
même une force de patrick sur la une et
que toute façon il faudra toujours
passer par les fourches caudines comme
j'aime la liberté sur l'a5
alors je suis très libre temps sera
maintenant tout le monde avait alors
trouvé une chaîne où il n'y ait pas
d'autres imitateur la 2 par exemple la
tête oui pour l'instant il n'a pas joué
alors j'y pense sérieusement là avec
quelques invités pathé pas brouiller dix
mois non mais je suis pas fâché avec les
comics sera livré avec les imitateurs
souvent il ya des
il ya quand même une certaine
concurrence qui joue j'ai constaté plus
récemment avait trop casse ah oui qu'est
ce qui l'attend est pas qu il a alors
c'est tout frais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé au coeur je vais présenter je vais
présenter l'émission de l'émission tf1
sur le rire avec hleb
ouais bon j'avais dit d'accord donc tu
vois je n'ai pas fâché avec l'un des
plus faibles genève des partis on a dit
c'est roucas qui présente les pires ou
cassady lecoq dit du mal de moi sur
canal donc je le parle le coeur y voilà
mais voilà tu vois qu'on n'est pas si
copains qui n'ont plus qu'à là je me dis
mon faisons une émission ça fait un
étalon un choix une chaîne plus petits
points communs pour un gala je prends
environ 100 mille francs 1 et quand même
peut-être des charges en plus ça fait
beaucoup par semaine
il me reste pas forcément 120 bien j'en
fais non j'en fais j'en suis 4 4 5 pas
moi mais je refais pas que ça surtout
ouais bah oui tu fais des nuls et plein
de trucs quoi oui les guignols lequel
romain l'arrivée à tout ça fait combien
par mois à peu près comme ça en passant
on chiffre d'affaires saas à quatre
cents 400 et pour moi c'est bien
sébastien étaient 800 un show qui leur
apportent ils ont quand tu es dans ta
voiture comme ça que tu rentres en
pleine nuit d'un gala il va vite le
chauffeur oui jean gérard est passé mais
je dorme je pense pas du tout aux
risques d'accidents tumeurs ont dormi à
vous c'est l'idéal ça sans voir arriver
les choses ce qui est un nouveau truc au
bord des routes
c'est encore de belles je sais pas on va
voir c'est de l'info si c'est de l'intox
prendre petit téléviseur tu vas voir
après le classique épouvantail pour les
joies jouer le plus élaboré mannequin
pour les autos voici la fosse voiture de
gendarmerie installés sur le bord des
routes pour décourager des chauffards
l'information a été révélée en détail il
y a quelques jours par le journal auto
plus on a su par quelques indiscrétions
qui est un fabricant de la région
parisienne qui avait été contacté pour
fabriquer des leurs et que l'entreprise
allait s'étendre dans les prochains mois
c'est un lecteur d'autoplus qui a
découvert le pot-aux-roses bernard gré
empruntent chaque jour la nationale 306
entre saclay et gif sur yvette et fin
janvier après plusieurs passages il été
surpris par la présence inopinée d'une
voiture de gendarmerie
vous savez ça ne fait pas partie du
paysage
vous passez à la même allure que
d'habitude c'est plutôt d'un chrétien
les flics
alors petit a fait le petit appel de sa
routine en face quand même ainsi
ce qui se passe deuxième coup mais pas
au même endroit pile alors là c'est ça
c'est là qu'ils cessent a mis la puce à
l'oreille la même endroit non non c'est
pas possible j'ai dit bon je prends mon
petit appareil un acteur qu'on va voir
et puis finalement je me suis carrément
arrêté je viens avec ses terres
c'est un bout de bois quoi pas de
commentaire du côté de la gendarmerie
prix pourtant en flagrant délit il est
évident que bernard gray a surpris une
opération lors d'une semaine test le
secret devait être gardé
quant aux producteurs même les plus
chevronnés avoue qu'il pourrait bien
tomber dans le panneau
quand je vois des voitures de police ou
de gendarmerie
eh bien on fait un petit peu plus
attention
donc le fait de croire qu'il va y avoir
une voiture de police ou de gendarmerie
va inciter à faire attention va inciter
à être méfiants et donc va améliorer
sécurité routière mais attention il faut
pas en mettre de trop parce que sur moi
mais de trop ce ne sera plus à l'heure
en prendra l'habitude et sony fera plus
attention et voiture leur utilisé par la
gendarmerie s de l'info ou de l'intox
patrick sébastien à l'oreille sur celle
de l'info est ce la tête ça tout est
joué bien aussi de l'intox et bonbons
parce que mon frère et gendarmes à la
gendarmerie dans leurs pas de calais et
qu' il m'a jamais parlé de ça donc j'y
crois pas je crois pas et toi alors
aussi bien d'autres pourquoi
sous-entendu
mais dis moi pourquoi quand je pose
c'est gratos par l'odeur l'agent double
toi qu'est ce que tu mérites à quai de
la fosse bien c'est l'expert philippe
guérin et will exquise et délicate
modestie plein de retenue de laurent
baffie va pouvoir une fois de plus
exprimé puisque son sosie est toujours
en tête puisque c'est de l'intox d'un
commentaire mon fils ou oui thierry un
grand merci à l'hebdomadaire auto plus
qui nous a aidés à monter cette intox
les voitures leur de police en france
pour l'instant c'est de l'intox mais en
grande bretagne c'est déjà de l'info à
où la police utilise ce type
d'instrument en france on en est loin
puisque notre équipe pour faire les
quelques photos vous avez vu avec une
fausse voiture de gendarmerie de quatre
mètres de long en bois a failli se
retrouver au poste
on applaudit
alors tu es content de donner score va
la jouer soft
ouais on va la jouer soft 3 2 pour
baffie le renard est toujours devant le
blaireau brabo
patrick bon on va te faire une petite
interview à penda d'accord le plus le
moins tu avais compris tu m'expliques
way qu'elle et l'imitateur pepsico qu'on
le dit qu'elle et l'imitateur que tu
préfères il ya patrick sébastien au kg
bien
enfin bon comme ce travail avec ce qu'on
peut dire qu'ils s'aiment bien encore
blanche marque si ouais c'est un mec que
j'ai découvert il est génial je vais me
lancer je vais pousser qui peut à
l'extérieur dehors les l'imitateur que
tu es le plus que je déteste
j'ai eu le coach de l'as d'or fait mon
sac au point que c'était ses copains
dans le showbiz par trois copains
le héros qui préfèrent agir est super
mal parce qu'il est quand même vachement
démerde avec les gonzesses koala qui je
sais pas il ya peu par ado c'est bien
que ça va vite l'aide est le héros que
tu détestes napoléon parce qu'il a quand
même fait vachement de mal avec ses
ailes toutes ces guerres tout ça enfin
j'adore parce que quand même s'il assure
basma que les gonzesses aussi
si tu donnes actrices préférées jackie
sardou parce que elle est belle elle est
pas et pas vulgaire du tout ça
des bols et l'actrice que tu déteste le
plus on voit sophie marceau ouais ouais
les bonnes ni combien cela dit j'adore
conduire quand elle veut dans l'émission
la star télé homme que tu préfères j'ai
bien patrick sébastien parce qu'il fait
bien son boulot mais chut je peux pas
trop dire parce que je connais bien
sinon michel drucker et ça même si
j'adore michel très gentils et vrais
seins très gentil mais ça je le remercie
parce que s'ils n'étaient pas là ce sera
peut-être pas là et la star télé homme
que tu veux pas saquer dorothée bon
enfin bon elle les gosses adorent alors
c'est vrai comme les gosses adorent ce
que voilà d'autres peuvent faire autre
chose que de doré parce que je suis là
c'est très grosse moi le plus grand
moment de la vie patrick voix c'est bon
la première émission sur tf1 c'est sûr
et le pire à la première édition de la
cote sur tf1 sa siège
ceux qui tiennent plus rien à la vie mes
conneries
c'est génial j'adore ces voix quelle
idée qui fait pareil ce qui n'est pas
rien la connerie les autres sachent que
je supporte connaître quelques fois ça
me fait marrer quand même quand c'est
moi qui le répète ainsi que c'est moi
dans ces cas-là ce que tu préfères en
toi patrouille je sais que j'ai besoin
de quelqu'un vachement marrant et puis
je sais pas j'aime bien j'ai bien beau
look est ce que tu supportes pas chez
toi ça semble un peu grave et ce
chantier du moins de temps plus gros
coup de fric
les indemnités de la salle parce que moi
j'ai été touché c'est quoi comme les
locaux qui n'a rien fait rien touché
pour la c5 dont il va encore se plaindre
il va encore se plaindre pendant des
années c'est polisseur état plus grosses
pertes c'est quoi au niveau pognon mais
ceci je pars de tf1 parce qu'il faut que
ce soit moi qui paie les indemnités que
je vais rester je crois qu'elle a la
pire chose qui pouvait arriver
aujourd'hui 6 2 face à face avec le coq
c'est vrai pour toi là tu pourrais pas
non et la meilleure chose c'est qu'ils
trouvent du boulot sur une autre chaîne
appuyé sur surtout si c'est pas en face
de moi que ça soit palette remué par
hasard non parce que moi on pourra
jamais empêcher de parler dire des
conneries tu es aveugle vertige je
pourrai toujours tâter bonfim commun
c'est pas pareil fait qu'à pirc aveugle
ou quoi mais c'est rencontrer baffier en
aveugle au réputé génie achat d'un
génial c'est moi qui l'ait découvrir
match il serait sain
coco si c'est ce qu'a dit le coach non
ma fille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais foutez moi la paix comment vous
allez vous allez me sall up lâchement
lagrave toi tu veux toi laissé tomber
ses parents en braille
voyant [__] les voyons c'est le but
non non non non c'est le 51 ici non ce
n'est pas un procès
ainsi monsieur je suis aveugle il faut
que je prenne moins chez prioritaires
j'ai une carte de priorité messieurs
tendance est arrivé c'est pas en cause
assure non non voilées ou par la pole
est fera [__] de josée lavoie et puis
taxi taxi avec soul on est où là
vous voulez on va chez vous alors
d'avoir huawei
on va chez vous pourquoi ça vous êtes de
passage à paris
voilà ça vous dirait d'avoir une
expérience avec un non voyant pourquoi
pas mais j'ai pas beaucoup de temps aux
missions et la petite jeune tu viens
elle a dit jonathan bien à l'hôtel par
l'entente pour moi faisait - merci je me
sens voisins vous prenez l'autobus et
vous descendez place de l'opéra le cadre
de la 21 d'importantes nuances et j'aime
bien savoir à qui j'ai affaire d'un tir
dans les voitures non non non non mais
j'ai pu y aller non je veux plus y aller
merci madame ah bon ya pas de moto là il
n'y a pas une honda dominator ya rien là
on m'a piqué ma bécane mer mais comment
je vais rentrer chez moi je suis pas ce
qu'est ce qui se passe
qui c'est qui c'est quoi qu'est ce qu'il
ya qu'est ce qu'il ya monique monique
pas ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe
c'est qui
1 voilà que c'est soit ça c'est votre
cul ça rend chez votre cul monsieur vous
me conseillez vers un monde dit qu'on
sait vers où nous dit quand le feu est
vert ya deux pour voulait traverser
avant sa stricte le hockey
nous développons louvre au cas où
opèrent à la matra mais trop lourd y a
bien offert à geoje là et bien oui les
rendent ainsi les 28 chefs
nous accueillir ceux du mois jean pierre
tu connais le coq très bien et paris qui
limite les reçoivent qui le fait un peu
nasillard match quand même c'est pas du
tout c'est un célibataire endurci non tu
trouves ça impossible et c'est vrai je
vais retrouver une fiancée dans une
émission d'ailleurs elle daté au moins
des années 60 générerait pas d'eau
depuis un contenu explique qu'il n'ait
pas envie de se marier le coq bien je ne
sais pas il paraît que lundi en
solitaire et notre époque peut-être
qu'ils allaient financiers nationaux
très punk
je ne comprends pas il a dit le la
question si vous lui demandez pas ce
qu'il a dit l'indépendance et la
fantaisie m'ont empêché de vivre la vie
de couple c'est bizarre quand sa femme
est loin d'être un signe à sa mère
il a eu une aventure à un moment avec
une fille qui s'appelait lydie deniers
as élément d'alliage shakil arabe uma
dessin c'est d'abord bien passée c'était
impressionnant
elle est repartie
c'est cette fille qui a les yeux violets
qui est bannie dans tarzan mais faisait
jane s'est terminé comme on en avait que
ce n'est pas de terminer paraît ça
marche toujours un sacré soirée qu'elle
survient toutes les vacances simplement
en fait 3 to support très bien la
solitude y venons avec gem 1 qui s'y
fait très bien il adore ça il adore ça
est ce que si tu trompes et affament
jean pierre tu lui dirai si celui-ci fit
dire à jean pierre fauque et est-ce que
tu qui traite ou pour le grand amour
aujourd'hui un jeu qui traite tous il
bien entendu je suis sponsorisé par une
grande compagnie d'aviation vrai prénom
est l'ancien messin est ce que tu fais
l'amour ailleurs que dans un lit
jean-pierre si on en fait elle est
sacrée soirée et avec des millions de
téléspectateurs sur scène j'en tire par
milliers chaque semaine ça laurence sans
tirage ne touche pas les mêmes
avec elle j'ai un pur sado maso à ceci s
a dit que amazon publie des revues
pornos oui six ans mes partenaires de
presque 1 attendu des reines ont
maintenant non déjà fait l'amour à
plusieurs chauffeurs mairie avec des
millions téléspectateurs j'espère que ce
sera encore plus nombreux la semaine
prochaine
c'est déjà allé dans un peep show non je
ne fume pas un truc
déjà utilisé des instruments des
godemichés des pinces à st non j'utilise
un ventilateur cinquième est steve c'est
vrai ça transpire beaucoup et des
expériences homosexuelles
j'avais chanté les siens avec patrick
savatier
ok c'est pour canal+ d'année sabbatique
ou courraient et j'ai peur zoophile
ah oui vraiment disney parade je me suis
tapé mickey minnie il est gros plus tôt
quand tu aimes
peux-tu tout faire au lit lorsque j'aime
certains je suis capable de tout faire
puisque chez capable de distribuer des
millions de centimes chaque semaine
paramore tu répondes si tu étais surpris
avec un garçon ce serait une sacrée
surprise
est ce que tu es poussé un hurlement
maintenant jean pierre simon
[Applaudissements]
le droitier ou gaucher eh bien écoutez
je me suis jamais posé la question je
pense plutôt droitier mais quand tu sais
droitière ce que j'aimerais souhaiter
spectacle voilà même endroit c'est un
drame
donc tu penses que tu es droitier je
suis inquiet c'est bien j'ai une autre
bonne nouvelle pour toi c'est pas
possible si c'est comme pour les gens
qui ont les yeux clairs en france avoir
surprise c'est une surprise
qu'est ce qui va venir maintenant ça va
t'il non regarde ton petit téléviseur
ils sont célèbres
adulé de john mcenroe à léonard de vinci
ou paul mccartney en passant par des
tôles charlie chaplin ou george bush
mais ne cédez pas à la tentation de les
envier car ils sont avant tout gaucher
conséquence leur vie est un perpétuel
sursis c'est ce qu'ont démontré deux
études américaines dont la plus récente
est paru dans la sérieuse revue de new
england journal of medecine les gauchers
vivent moins longtemps que les droitiers
9 ans - pour les hommes à droite
six ans de moins pour les femmes les
causes en serait d'abord physiologique
il semblerait que le gaucher soit plus
vulnérables en particulier à certaines
maladies
elle m'a dit qu'on appelle des maladies
auto immunes ce qui ferait penser donc
le système immunitaire et doit préparer
à réagir mais les vraies raisons de
cette différence ont tout simplement
liés à l'environnement
tout est conçu pour les droitiers les
poignées de portes les ciseaux les
couteaux bref la vie du gaucher est un
combat tout instant et ce dès le plus
jeune âge
au départ ça pose des premières
écritures parce que dès qu'on écrit à la
plume forcément passe la main sur ce
qu'on vient d'écrire et ça fait des
cahiers qui sont toujours mal tenu et on
avait une réputation de quelqu'un qui
s'est donc hissé mal écrire ou mal
présenté les choses bien souvent m'a pas
pris pour un handicapé ne pas loin quand
les gauchers aurait 25 % de plus
d'accidents du travail est six fois plus
d'accidents de voiture des conclusions
qui pourrait faire réfléchir les
sociétés d'assurance vie
certaines demandent déjà aux
contractants s'ils sont obèses s'ils
fument ou s'ils boivent et les surtaxes
si ces éléments s'additionnent ce
critère pour être retenu par les
assureurs s'il est vrai que les
statistiques prouvent que les droitiers
et les gauchers ou une espérance de vie
plus importante là effectivement ça
pourrait peut-être les prêts aux comptes
ils représentent 10% de la population
mondiale on a tout dit sur leur compte
d'après la rumeur il serait plus souvent
efféminé voir homosexuels plus gauche
tout simplement
maintenant on leur reproche d'être moins
résistants honnêtement ça m'impressionne
pas du tout parce que je préfère avoir
une vie bien remplie y est plus courte
qu'une vie plus longue et ennuyeuse
ils sont entrés dans l'histoire et pas
toujours du pied gauche mais à quel âge
vont-ils en sortir
vrai plus longtemps que les gauchers s
de l'info s de l'intox
jean pierre foucault à l'oreille alors
elle après celle de la taxe
alors maintenant pendant que vous
demandez si c'est de l'intox ou de
l'info pendant que guérir
il réfléchit plus qu'est-ce qu'on écoute
corti ouais ça va pas non mais c'est
mais c'est ma cousine
je te jure que c'est ma cousine c'est
pour le tirage c'est pour tirer leçon
alors on dira quoi là on tire marconne à
papa tu as mal marcos ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes à bout ce we choose
pour le prix
jackson
de plus
devenu sirène on s'est endormi
je te refais crastus blanc
ok ok
ce soir quelle est ma fille tu sèmes
fils
bio
pour qu'il me veut
m
102 kostova bon vieux maire
[Musique]
partout
la sécurité des nations
jusqu'à ce jour
sauf que
van kempen
[Applaudissements]
ok
tous
wargame à pitre
que le maire
tous
pour mme abou switches beaulieu compris
[Musique]
m
je me lave paris v
[Musique]
m
plus longtemps que les gauchers s de
l'info est de l'intox c'est tout est
joué la fidh basse et de la faune soit
de l'info pourquoi vous vois dans les
bases compter droitier du monde droite
toit de gauche et qui fait quoi tu
prends le droit de l'enfant si ce
morceau enfants qui fait quoi mais n'a
joué un endroit qui aimons droite c'est
de voir tout est bien comme ton modèle
et toi c'est de l'info alors jean pierre
foucault m'a dit que c'était de l'intox
lui à moi je veux dire un faux en tous
les cas si c'est de l'info pour toi
c'est génial parce que tu fais les yeux
clairs sorti de l'auberge tuer les yeux
clairs mais j'ai droitier tu vas nous
faire un centenaire là on écoute
l'expert philippe guérin
et oui mon sosie et moi même sommes
peut-être perdant au jeu ce soir mais
gagnant sur un autre tableau puisque
nous sommes tous les deux est droitier
et nous avons les yeux clairs c'était de
l'info est ce que tu aurais par hasard
une idée du score a le score c'est
évident bâti parcours sans faute 4 3
enfin bravo
alors mon petit lolo tu prends ton petit
téléviseur
tu regardes les canaux philips qui
défilait tu me dis celui que tu veux
[Musique]
le tricheur c'est quoi ma faim en mars
la presse et de la domotique
le téléviseur mcfly 70 cm effet cela un
tri standard pal secam nds est acquis
chage sur écran avec menu utilisateurs
bravo ma fille et toi fini tu as gagné
quelque chose de plus important encore
notre état et notre estime
on l'applaudît ans n'a pas dit qu'il est
bien
alors ton père était officier de marine
yves fortes chances qu'ils étaient
catholiques étaient catholiques et
touahri quand moi je ne suis pas
pratiquant mais je suis catholique je
suis moyen je sais même pas ce que c'est
que la religion catholique et la
compréhension du connaît la confession
jeu que j'ai connu ouais tu arrêtes
confessé avec moi dans un coin sombre
oui mais là je crois qu'ils les caméras
non non non bon alors ça va ça va là tu
viens avec moi ok yves lecoq mesdames
messieurs
les
[Musique]
ce que tu crois en dieu oui il arrive de
prier des fois oui à ma manière
d'ailleurs ça peut être dans une église
ça peut être ça peut être n'importe où
le simple fait d'un internement d'avis
une fois que c'était arrivé c'était
quand le privé ça va pas remonter si
loin que ça j'ai déjà dit prier je vais
pas c'était quoi ça peut être pour
enrayer le fléau de certaines personnes
qui s'abattent sur certaines personnes à
l'adie des gens qu'on aime c'est une
amie qui est malade et fait prier pour
lui j'ai une amie qui sortent de ce qui
est soi disant maladie cram
je pense que ça peut avoir un effet de
twitter et aussi de prier pour des amis
qui ne s'en sont pas sortis pour autant
mais ça n'empêche pas essayer est ce que
tu crois pas que
aujourd'hui dans ta carrière tu n'es pas
encore complètement débloqué veux pas te
montrer tels que tu es aux gens et
finalement c'est un blocage qui avait
bloqué ce qui te nuit sur le plan
professionnel j'ai essayé de comprendre
sa de 500 jeux
une période de livres qui étaient donc
avant l'adolescence où l'âge était
spontanée après s'agit de bloquer par
différents de bâtard de ma vie et
c'est vrai que je joue j'ai l'impression
d'en sortir un peu je pense que c'est
bénéfique évident de ne pas tricher avec
soi même c'est tellement la meilleure
solution
quand on part de ta vie privée par
exemple qui est lui toujours les
questions pourront non parce que ça la
vie privée par pratiquement comme son
nom l indique l es personnel j'aime me
garder aussi j'ai pas envie que la rue
on me disent alors comment ça va à côté
du terrain je vous avais dit ceci ou
cela est ce que je peux faire quelque
chose pour vous ça ne regarde que moi tu
crois que tu te regret c'est qu'un jour
je serai complètement libérés ou que tu
vas rester bloqué comme non non j'espère
me libérer avant qu'elle soit disant
parce que je crois que c'est vivre vieux
d'apprêter d'apprêter info ou intox
c'est ce qu'on souhaite en tout cas
merci
oh
[Musique]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu